Well…
BlackPink: Light
Up The World.
Hello!
I'm Lee Jung-jae from
Squid Game.
-Park Hae-soo.
-Wi Ha-jun.
And Jung Ho-yeon.
Let's talk about…
the preferences of the
Squid Game cast…
-right here in…
-My Netflix.
The game is starting.
The one we used
to play as kids?
The rules are simple.
Let's start.
I think I know
what Hae-soo wrote.
No way.
Yes way.
I think I know what
Jung-jae wrote.
Done!
I did my research
in advance.
I made a list.
-I'm still not done yet…
-Michael Jordan?
Michael Jordan:
The Last Dance
Rock, paper,
scissors, shoot!
For the start, of course,
Squid Game.
The Two Popes.
How did I miss that?
Peaky Blinders.
Yes.
I knew you would write that.
How?
Night in Paradise.
Roma.
-Roma.
-Roma?
BLACKPINK: Light
Up The World.
Seriously?
New World.
Got it.
You crossed the line!
Misaeng.
You need two bingos, right?
I should be done
by now then.
-Already?
-Really?
Dark.
Dark?
It's a German show.
It's so good.
The Highwaymen.
D.P.
Alright, I have that.
Marriage Story.
Comrades: Almost
a Love Story.
Bingo!!
I've watched the
shows on my board
multiple times so
I can guarantee
that they're
my all-time favourites.
I'm not that
really that picky.
I just watch everything.
And then think
"Hey I like this."
I'm not gonna tell
anybody about this.
That's what I do.
Prison Playbook.
The classic.
And Time to Hunt.
Another classic.
I think I like new
and interesting subjects.
Like Man Hunt or Narcos.
The era that I have
not experienced.
And the art direction.
That's what I expect to see.
I think that's the theme
of my bingo board.
That's what I got from it.
I like two types of genre.
Noir
and realistic stories,
about human nature and mind.
Like Marriage
Story or Misaeng.
Extracurricular.
Time to Hunt, New World.
I think I watched New World
30 times whilst in the army.
For real.
I watched it about 20 times.
If you are a man.
I didn't know
this but I think
I like stories
about human life.
Stories that are touching
and emotional.
Just like Marriage Story.
Comrades: Almost
A Love Story.
And Maudie with Ethan Hawke.
It's a biographical drama.
Most of them are about love.
BLACKPINK: Light
Up The World.
I can't really call myself
a fan of BLACKPINK but
Ho-yeon and Jennie
are great friends.
Jennie actually visited us
with a coffee truck.
I was like Wow! That's
Jennie from BLACKPINK!
It was cool.
When I watched the trailer
I thought
Wow, so that's how BLACKPINK
became the world
famous girl group.
All because of
their hard work.
Then I became their fan.
He recommended it to me,
so I watched it.
I have a couple of
great documentaries
that I want to recommend.
Don't F**k with Cats.
I think it captures
the viewer's attention
really well.
It was more powerful
that reading the article.
It was very shocking.
Michael Jordan:
The Last Dance.
As I watched that
I was amazed at
how they directed everything
so well while handling
all kind of emotions.
It's a beautiful
show for sure.
My favourite documentary is
Headspace: Guide to Sleep.
That's the title.
When I can't sleep,
I follow their
guided meditation.
Before I know, I'm asleep.
It's so helpful!
So I recommend that.
Explain is a series
of short documentaries.
There are a lot of topics.
Sound, skin, stock markets.
I think it's
a documentary that
makes us question
about things.
It definitely made me
question things
that I normally wouldn't.
I look it up if I'm curious.
And talk about it
with my friends.
I think it's very
inspirational.
Peaky Blinders.
It's a TV series.
It's about the Shelby
family in England
just after WWI.
The gangster
family gradually
takes over
the political world.
I liked the colour,
the background,
the trauma behind
the characters
and how the actors
play out their characters.
The outfits,
the art direction
about that era was
really beautiful.
There was a lot
to learn from
so I really adore the show.
The filming staff
also recommended
Peaky Blinders.
He really likes
Cillian Murphy
so I got into it, too.
My favourite…
I love them all.
I recently watched D.P.
I served in the army, too.
I wasn't a D.P. but
I was an MP.
When I was in the army
it wasn't as bad
as the show but
it must have been like that
for the people before me.
It made me angry and upset.
Watching the stories
about the runaway soldiers,
I related myself to them.
It was therapeutic.
I loved Cho
Hyun-cheol's acting
I debuted with China Town.
And he played Hong-joo
I loved him there, too.
And in D.P.
He was an otaku
Private First Class.
Later in the show,
he totally changed
and it was very impactful.
I think if you have Netflix,
you probably watched and
enjoyed Money Heist.
I got into Netflix because
of Money Heist in a way.
Season 5 will be out soon.
I'm looking forward to it.
So excited.
I'm a big fan
of Money Heist.
It's such an honour and
I'm super nervous.
In the original version,
Berlin is kind of chic
and cold-blooded.
He's on the verge
of good and evil.
But in the Korean version,
Berlin has a good
reason to be like that.
So it'll be
completely different.
I wanted to
portray Berlin as
a real human being.
So it'll be very different
from the original.
My favourite is
Roma.
I think it was after I got
casted for Squid Game.
It was her first time acting
as the heroine of Roma.
So I got comforted
from her acting.
When I'm feeling tired
or when I'm feeling lost,
I go back to the show
to refresh myself.
So I'd like to
recommend this show.
I think you guys
are into mysteries.
There's a show called Dark.
It's really interesting
and the subject is unique.
The story starts with the
disappearance of a child.
This is not a spoiler.
It's not?
The story develops
as they uncover
the secrets they've been
hiding from each other.
Which ends up destroying
the whole town.
It's so interesting
I couldn't stop watching.
-Dark.
I heard this recently.
About bonfire on Netflix.
What's that?
If you type in bonfire
It shows you a
burning bonfire.
-It just pops up?
-Yeah.
It's great
when I'm drinking alone.
Squid Game in one word?
Attractive.
My heart jumped a bit
when I heard his voice.
I am quite attractive.
I think it's the
power of drama.
I think it's indispensable.
The setting is adorable,
in contrast to
the people's lives!
The plot twist intensifies
as the episodes go on!
I think that's the
highlight.
We all like different
kinds of shows.
Just like that,
Squid Game is filled
with different
genres and
interesting stories.
Squid Game. Stay tuned.
See you on Netflix.